CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Hi.
I'm Cliff Lungaretti.
Welcome to another
Talk at Google.
I'm a member of the
Talks at Google program,
and it's a pleasure
to have you guys here.
It's also a pleasure to
have Adam Garone, the CEO
and co-founder of the Movember
Foundation, with us here today.
So Adam, welcome to Google.
ADAM GARONE: Thank you.
Thank you for having us.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
You're very welcome.
So let's just jump
right into it.
Let's talk about
Movember and see
who actually knows
about Movember
and what we can tell
them out in the world.
So just as bare
bones as possible.
ADAM GARONE: Right.
Yeah, so Movember-- the month
formally known as November--
it's a campaign to raise funds
and awareness for men's health.
So three causes that we
fund-- prostate and testicular
cancers, the two male-only
cancers; and also mental health
challenges that men face.
And for the first
time in the US,
a portion of the funds on
the back of this campaign
will go to that cause.
The 101 stuff-- men sign up,
start the month clean shaven,
grow a mustache for the
30 days, and effectively
become walking, talking
billboards for men's health.
And then we have a
Mo Sistas program
for the women that want to
participate in the campaign.
A very, very important
part of Movember
is women that are
often the gatekeepers--
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: A lot
of Mo Sistas in the house.
Thank you for joining
us, Mo Sistas.
ADAM GARONE: Yeah.
The gatekeepers to
allowing us to grow
a mustache in the first place.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: So Movember's
been around for how long?
ADAM GARONE: 2003.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: 2003.
And how did Movember
start, since you're
a co-founder of the
Movember Foundation?
ADAM GARONE: In sort of
traditional Australian way.
It was over beers on a
summer afternoon and--
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Approved.
ADAM GARONE: It was
my brother and a mate,
and they were talking
about fashion.
And they were
talking about trends
and how things eventually come
back into style-- and then
was 2003.
And the conversation then turned
to what hasn't made a comeback.
And they could think of two
things-- macrame and mustaches.
And so our next campaign will
be to bring back macrame.
A few more beers and the
day ended with a challenge
to bring back the mustache.
And really, the initial idea
was to put the mustache back
on the face of fashion.
So "mo" is slang for
mustache in Australia,
so the month was renamed.
And 30 of us
participated in 2003.
And we were literally the only
late 20-year-old, 30-year-old
guys rocking
mustaches back then.
And the response
was amazing, really,
and shocking because
people would just
stop and go, why
are you doing that?
And boss wouldn't let me go
and see clients and things
like that.
And it just generated
so many conversations
that at the end of the campaign,
the four of us got together
and we thought, let's
put this toward a cause.
And we were inspired
by the women around us
and what they were
doing for breast cancer,
and just thought there's
nothing for men's health.
So that became the merger of
the two activities-- growing
a mustache and men's health.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: How much
money did you raise in 2003?
ADAM GARONE: No money.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: No money.
No, it was literally an
excuse to grow a mustache,
have a mustache [INAUDIBLE].
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
When we get to 2004,
how much money do you raise?
ADAM GARONE: Yeah,
2004, we had 450 guys
sign up and participate,
and we raised $54,000.
And it was the single biggest
donation, the Prostate Cancer
Foundation in Australia,
had ever received.
And that year changed our lives.
And since then, on the back of
all the funds that were raised,
literally means men's lives have
been impacted by the campaign.
So yeah, long story short, over
the years, we've had 4 million
Mo Bros and Mo Sistas sign up.
We've raised $580 million,
$135 million last year.
The foundation is now
the biggest funder
of prostate and testicular
cancer research in the world.
So yeah, it's been
an amazing journey.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Awesome.
Well, it's great
to have you here.
And actually, I'm not going
to throw it to a video
as now that we've
discussed what is Movember,
we're going to just show a
little shiny thing if we could.
Let you have a glass of water.
All right.
So if we can cue that up, Dave.
Thanks, man.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-A movement is the
power of people inspired
by a common passion that
is determined for change.
A movement can be sparked by
something pretty unlikely.
We are Movember.
-We shave down on the
first, and for 30 days,
raise awareness and
funds for men's health
by growing mustaches.
We were born over a few
years in a Australia.
We are now in over
21 countries, making
us the largest men's health
movement in the world.
-We are Mo Bros, and we
at our strongest when
we stay true to who we
are-- real men growing
real mustaches talking
about real issues.
We're a global community
standing together,
welcoming each and every
Mo Bro and Mo Sista
as a friend and
fellow change agent.
-We sign up in
Movember.com in October
and raise funds in Movember
for prostate cancer, testicular
cancer, and men's
mental health problems.
-Our mustache is our hairy
ribbon, our badge of honor.
Grow a mustache this Movember
or support those who do.
Together, we can change
the face of men's health.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: I
joked with you earlier
that I blame my entire career
trajectory on my mustache.
So I know we've talked about
how you said you weren't allowed
to go to client meetings
with your mustache.
And how do you feel
that you've actually
been able to use the Movember
Foundation and the Movember
movement to actually affect
the fashion statement that you
were talking about?
ADAM GARONE: Yeah.
I mean, it's been
interesting over the years
to watch grooming trends change.
And I'm positive Movember had
a fair bit to do with that.
And we arguably have
put the mustache back
on the face of fashion.
And it's gone even
further than that now.
And beards are in style
for the most part, as well.
So it's been interesting
to watch that,
and there's so many
layers to Movember,
and I often think
about grooming trends
and how that relates
to masculinity
and the shift in masculinity
over the last sort of 15 years.
And you post that phase
of being a metrosexual
or whatever that
actually ever meant,
probably 10 years
ago, men started
to express their masculinity
through facial hair.
And it's been a very,
very interesting journey.
And it's to the extent
now where we even
need to bring the
mustache back again.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Well, I
think interesting you mentioned
beards, and I do
know whenever you
talk to somebody
about, hey, you should
grow a mustache this Movember,
everyone's just like, oh
yeah, I'm going to not
shave, which I know something
that we've had with Movember
and then the No-Shave-member
and all of the
stuff that happens.
So if we could just
definitively explain
why it is the mustache
and not the beard.
ADAM GARONE: Yeah.
For us, it's about creating
a conversation that matters.
And our tagline is "Changing
the face of men's health."
So it's literally about
changing your appearance,
and whether that's going clean
shaven when you've normally
got a beard and then
growing a mustache.
And when you do
that, it generates
so many conversations.
It's quite amazing how changing
your appearance like that
does create interest in people.
And I always say
to guys that are
on the edge about doing
Movember the first time
or have done it a few
times and are contemplating
having a year off, I always
say that I guarantee you,
because of Movember and
because of your mustache,
you'll have one really
significant conversation.
And I've been doing this
12 years, I think, now.
Every year that I do Movember,
I have at least one conversation
that makes it all worthwhile.
Forget sort of the
funds that are raised.
And it's quite amazing.
We've commissioned some
research around how
do we get men more engaged
in their health beyond just
Movember.
And there's so many nuances to
approach men with this view.
If you go directly to
men on their health,
typically we shut down.
And it's so interesting that
the research we did sort of
uncovered that the women,
generally speaking,
are very good at having
face to face conversations,
like physically face to face
conversations, where men are
far more comfortable
having shoulder to shoulder
conversations,
particularly when there's
something else going on.
And for us, it's the act
of growing a mustache
and doing that shoulder to
shoulder with someone else.
And that creates
this environment
that the conversation
starts about how good or bad
your mustache is and then goes
over into often really quite
serious issues that
we don't normally
have a bridge to get to.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Very true.
So we talked about the causes.
As you said this year,
you're doing mental health
for the first time.
So what's brought us there?
ADAM GARONE: Yeah.
Movember's always
been holistically
about men's health.
And people often ask us, why
do you focus on men's health?
The state of men's health
and in boys and men
is significantly worse
than girls and women.
And on average, a man dies five
years younger than a woman,
and there's no biological
reason for that.
And over the years, the
average age has been going up
and the gap is closing
between men and women
living the same amount of time.
And no one's really
putting a focus on that.
And I mean, five years is a
significant amount of time.
And we know that
if we can improve
the state of men's
health-- and I'm
talking physically
and mentally here--
that will improve
society as a whole.
Children, women, everyone
will benefit from that.
So that's why we're focused
on men's health holistically.
Our first cause that we decided
to support was prostate cancer.
And as we dove into
this, people often
go-- because one of the
other co-founder's is
my brother-- people often
assume that our dad was
sick from prostate
cancer and that
was part of the inspiration.
And we often joke now that, no,
he had a really sick mustache
back in the day and that
was more the inspiration.
But started to dive into and
research the cancers that
affect men-- and
there's two-- and then
we were just shocked
that prostate cancer has
the same social impact
as breast cancer.
Roughly the same number
of men are diagnosed,
roughly the same amount of
men pass from prostate cancer
as women with breast cancer.
And you only need
to look around now
during October, Breast
Cancer Awareness Month,
to see the amazing number of
cause marketing initiatives
for that cause.
And if you sort of take
Movember off the table,
there's really
nothing else out there
of any sort of scale
or significance
for prostate cancer.
So that became
our initial focus.
And then when we got
some scale, we then
also started to attack
testicular cancer.
And that's a rare,
highly curable disease,
but it's the most
common cancer that
affects young men--
so 17 to sort of 35.
And as you know, a lot of the
guys participating in Movember
are in that age range,
versus prostate cancer
is a disease that when
you're in your 40s plus,
you need to be
really conscious of.
And so that was
the initial focus.
And then mental health.
And we often get asked,
well, obviously, that
affects men and women.
But when you dive
into that issue
and look at the
statistics, it's really
quite a sad story for men.
So three out of four
suicides are men.
Men often don't understand
the signs and symptoms
of a mental illness.
Men are typically
good at masking those,
whether it's diving into
work, whether it's drinking,
or whatever it is, and
not good at seeking help.
And in the US, it's about 83
men a day take their lives.
And so often, imagine
if 83 guys washed
on the shores of, say, Santa
Monica Beach tomorrow morning.
That would be global
and national news.
And then it happened
the next day
and the next day
and the next day.
And it's just an issue that
is not being spoken about,
and we're putting
the a large torch
to this in terms of the issue
from a mile perspective.
So it's really four causes--
men's health holistically,
prostate and testicular
cancer, and then mental health.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
A lot of times when
I talk to somebody about growing
a mustache, if someone refuses,
I always just ask them
to do me one favor
and to actually go to the doctor
and get their yearly physical
and get all those things
checked out, because I think
that's the best thing you can
do if you actually don't want
to physically change your
face, to at least do that.
So I think that's usually
my bargaining chip of you
really should grow a mustache,
but if you don't really
want to, at least do this
for me because that's
the conversation there.
So it's very interesting to
know those suicide facts.
It's really actually
unexpectedly harrowing.
ADAM GARONE: Yeah.
I mean, then there's different
segments of the community.
So if you look at the
military, more men
have taken their lives after
serving in Iraq and Afghanistan
than died in the battlefield.
And that is a shocking outcome.
And again, it's a
really complex issue.
With prostate and
testicular cancer,
we're on the path to effectively
curing both of those diseases.
And what we mean by that is
we will soon be at a stage
where no man should die from
either of those diseases.
For sure, if a guy doesn't
present and he's got an issue,
he will pass from
testicular cancer.
There's no doubt about that.
But through ongoing
awareness, education,
getting guys going
to the doctor,
there's one last piece of the
puzzle with testicular cancer,
and we've just launched a
global collaborative research
initiative to the tune
of about $3 million,
bringing together the
best minds to solve
that last bit of the puzzle.
And then it'll
effectively be cured.
Prostate cancer is a
more complex disease.
We help fund at the
University of Michigan
the identification of 28
types of prostate cancer.
And we know of those prostate
cancers which are aggressive,
and it's about 20% of them
are aggressive and need
radical treatment.
So that could be
surgery or radiation.
But 80% are
slow-growing, indolent,
and guys can live
with that cancer
if it stays within the prostate.
Normally, it's OK.
The issue at the moment
is with prostate cancer,
we can't tell a guy definitively
what type of prostate cancer
he's got.
So a lot of guys are
rushing in and having
surgery or radiation.
And the real issue with
that is the side effects
from those treatments.
So it strikes everything
it is to be a man.
It's like incontinence,
impotence, bowel disorder,
depression, let alone
the financial burden that
goes with it.
So that's the big
contentious issue
with prostate cancer
at the moment.
We don't have a
great screening test.
And there's a lot
of debate around
should you get screened or not.
Lot of confusion in the public
and also with GPs around it.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: I
think one of the things--
I saw you speak maybe two,
three years ago, when you said
that you wanted Movember
not to be the charity that
raised money for
prostate cancer.
You wanted it to
be the charity that
kept moving on to new
diseases and new issues.
So it's great to hear that
there is progress being made
and we are taking on
new and exciting things.
ADAM GARONE: Yeah.
And it's interesting, like as
we got into the whole research--
well, particularly with
prostate and testicular cancer--
it's really interesting in
how that industry, for want
of a better term, has
been sort of structured.
And it's all around competition,
and they will compete and spend
so much time putting together
proposals for limited grants,
and they get notoriety by
getting written up in journals,
and then more funding
comes off the back of that.
And it was about
five years ago, we
were in six countries
at that stage,
and we didn't [INAUDIBLE]
the research we were doing.
And there were common
themes and people actually
researching exactly the same
thing across those countries.
And we sort of said to
the guys here in New York,
do you know the guys
in Sydney and London
and Montreal that are
researching the same thing?
And they didn't, in many
cases, know each other existed
let alone collaborate.
So a fundamental principle for
us now is around collaboration.
And typically, the
only thing that gets
collaborated is a
breakthrough in a journal.
And what's so
important-- and you guys
know this-- is sharing
what doesn't work,
and then people can iterate
off the back of that.
So Movember's truly
uniquely placed
to have this influence because
we're in 21 countries now
with a major funder, so you
get to define the rules,
haven't you, when you're
handing out these funds.
And a key principle now
is around collaboration.
And for us, we want to unite
this research community
and get them working together.
And it's quite a cultural
shift for those researchers
to get to that stage.
They're normally
used to competing.
So it's been a really
interesting process.
And I often think
about this journey,
and one of the key ingredients
for our success, I think,
over time has been naivete.
The four of us that
started Movember had never
worked in charity, had no idea
around how to run a charity.
We're all sales, business
development type people.
And we just came at it
from a brand perspective
and infused that
with technology.
And we sort of disrupted
the way you could possibly
raise awareness and
funds for a cause.
And in the same way, when we
get into this research world,
you just stand back and go, the
way you guys are operating just
doesn't make sense.
Why don't you collaborate?
And there was no reason to.
There was absolutely no
reason to collaborate.
So for us, disrupting
that environment
and getting these
guys in the same room
is so critically important--
and then virtually connected
as well.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
Very interesting.
Now let's jump.
I feel like we've
gotten really deep
on some cancer things,
some sad things.
So let's get back to the fact
that we're growing mustaches
and we're having a good time.
ADAM GARONE: Having
fun doing it.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
All right, and we're
having a great time doing it.
And that's why we all
are grow mustaches
for all the good
reasons, but also
because it's a good
time and it's fun.
So let's throw on the 2014
Made in Movember campaign
for this year.
If we could throw that on, Dave.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Making things.
Getting it grown.
Because what we make in life,
what we do for others makes us.
Doing something, even
just making conversation
or making time for someone, it's
a reality check on your health
and a responsibility
to take action.
Makers.
Thinkers.
Growers.
Doers.
Changing the face
of men's health.
We are Made in Movember.
Sign up, grow, and
donate at Movember.com.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: So this
year it's Made in Movember.
I know we have many Movember
mates all around the world
in Google, and I
know that we seem
that we're pushing a
this moustache is made
in America this year, this
moustache is made in Ireland.
So is this more of a drive
to competition for that?
ADAM GARONE: Yeah.
So we each year, we come up
with a new campaign creative,
and again, it comes back
to treating a brand as sort
of central to
everything that we do.
And we treat it almost
like a fashion brand,
and each year there's a
new style and a new theme.
So this year is
Made in Movember.
And the literal
interpretation of it
is the mustache is
made in Movember,
the man is made in Movember.
But the inspiration for it
came from this whole makers
movement, this whole
movement back to locally
grown, locally produced, the
farms to tables movement.
And it's really
interesting to see--
and I think it was in part
driven by the economy,
and also in part driven
by access to things
like Kickstarter and stuff like
that where people have a way
to raise a little
bit of capital to get
their idea off the ground.
And it's quite amazing to
see how many maker fairs
and things that are going on.
But yeah, it's really about
locally grown and locally grown
mustaches.
And we've sort of even taken
it down to a city level,
so Made in Movember New
York or Montreal or--
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: As the
captain of the Google New York
team from Movember,
I have already
called out the
Mountain View team
that we're going to
beat them this year.
And I actually am not afraid
to say that last year, I
was the highest raising
Googler in the entire world,
so that was exciting.
ADAM GARONE: Congratulations.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
So just saying.
Thank you.
ADAM GARONE: Who won last year?
New York or--?
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: I don't want
to say who won that battle.
I just want to say that--
AUDIENCE: Who won per capita?
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: I'm sorry?
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: I'm not
sure, actually, truthfully.
Sorry.
ADAM GARONE: But it'd have
to be you guys, wouldn't it?
Per capita, per head count.
How many people you got here?
Like 25,000 people here, right?
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: I don't know.
We'll see.
But we gotta look into that.
Actually, do we want to
jump into a little bit
of technology.
ADAM GARONE: Sure.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
And has Movember
changed almost the face the
way charity works almost?
ADAM GARONE: Yeah.
So there's been a
couple of things
that we've held central, which
is the brand and then also
the technology.
And back in 2004, when we
first sort of cobbled together
our very first website, we've
developed our own technology
right from the start.
And there's a lot of white
labeled platforms out there
now, which make this whole
landscape a little bit
different.
But for us at Movember,
with our technology what
we've tried to do is create,
really, a social media
platform albeit
around a cause and
albeit around a
short period of time,
and injecting in that
ways for the community
to come together online, to
communicate with each other,
to check out what's going on in
different parts of the world,
but with a collective vision.
And as you know, one of the
key things we've built in here
is layers and layers and
layers of competition,
because obviously that drives
fundraising within a team,
within a city, within a
country or an organization.
So it really is interesting
because our technology
platform, we raised
last year $135 million,
and that was in essentially
a six-week period.
So if you sort of
amortize over the year,
it's like at least a billion
dollar e-commerce platform.
But the challenge
our guys have is we
have an avalanche
of traffic that
starts to ramp up now and
then throughout November.
So one of our
challenges is we only
get to do this once a year,
so the tuning we're doing
and the testing and the
experiments the guys
are doing on different
buttons and different paths,
we do a lot of that
in October, and then
we sort of lock it down because
we can't afford for their to be
any issues with the platform.
But it is interesting that
even though we are a charity,
people expect the
technology experience, be it
on mobile or on a computer, to
be as good as they experience
at Google or
Facebook or Instagram
or whatever it is
they're used to using.
When they come across to us and
it's not as seamless to sign up
or whatever it is,
they're out the door.
And so we spend a lot of
time thinking about the user
interface and the
paths people go down
to make it as simple and
as intuitive as possible.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Interesting.
And how does the technology in
the Movember programs kind of
come together?
ADAM GARONE: Yeah, there's a
couple of areas that we do.
So the collaboration piece that
I talked about, one of the ways
we get the researchers
collaborating
is through a sort of
Wiki-based platform.
So again, it was
an off the shelf
product that we've packaged up.
And yeah, they are able to
come together online and share
things.
And it's quite
amazing that you see
these conversations happening.
There will be a
researcher saying--
I think it was the
Netherlands posed
a question in a
particular forum,
and then there was a guy,
I think, from New York--
a researcher-- that
said, hey, yeah, we've
been down this path.
Here are all the results.
It ended in this.
I wouldn't suggest
going down that path
because it didn't lead anywhere.
So for that, the researchers
in the Netherlands
then iterate off
of that, and then
that whole community
that's focused
on that particular project,
to able to observe that
is really, really powerful.
The other thing that
we're doing-- as I say,
we'll get to a stage
where we'll effectively
cure these diseases,
but it doesn't
mean we've got a vaccine
coming anytime soon that'll
wipe them off the table.
So as we live older,
there's going to be more men
and their families going through
the prostate or testicular
cancer journey--
particularly prostate.
And so we're
developing new program.
It's called True North.
It's our biggest
investment ever.
It's like $40 million globally.
That's going to provide a
whole range of applications
and products to allow
the guy and his family
to navigate through
this whole journey.
And the journey being from
the time of diagnosis,
through treatment, and
then life after treatment.
So it'll help them
access clinical trials.
It'll advise them on
optimal diet and exercise.
It'll connect them
with other people going
through the same journey if they
want to chat with other men,
or the caregivers
can do that as well.
It'll sure, if you're
in New York, what
facilities and things
that are around you,
and similarly with wherever
you are in the country.
Because one of the big
issues is the access often
that you have to
medical services
is defined by where you live.
And if you live in
New York, there's
an amazing array of
institutions, organizations,
and research going on.
But if you're
Alabama or somewhere,
there's just not, and so being
able to through technology
connect everyone.
And there's a quarter
of a million guys
a year get diagnosed just in
the US with prostate cancer.
So we're just starting
down that path now,
and we've connected about 10
institutions across the US
to work on this
technology platform.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: That's great.
Is there anybody here in the
house that has any questions?
We have two microphones
in the aisle ways.
If anyone wants to step up,
I'll just throw it over to you.
But just let me know.
I think we've got some
lights coming on over those.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Any particular
mustache style you think
should be stopped and
not allowed to occur?
ADAM GARONE: Well, there's
the obvious one, isn't there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM GARONE: Yeah, the-- well,
we call it a Charlie Chaplin.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
It's the Chaplin.
Yeah.
ADAM GARONE: Yeah,
it's the Chaplin, which
he did a lot of bad
shit, and one of them
was banishing that style.
So yeah, that
would be the go-to.
AUDIENCE: The more real
question is you clearly
didn't set out your
life to do this.
It's become a passion of yours.
What keeps you involved
year after year?
ADAM GARONE: Yeah, it's
funny you say that.
It's like every day
I wake up and go,
somehow my life has
become about a mustache.
And when you stop, step
back, and think about it,
it's ridiculous
that this happened.
But it's far more than that now.
And I often talk about a
lot and think about a lot
the difference between
being successful and being
significant.
I think on reflection, we
spend a lot of-- the first half
of our life trying
to be successful,
and whether that's academics,
with sports, with work, getting
more promotions and
all that sort of stuff.
I think-- and certainly
for me on reflection--
there was a point
in my life where
that was great, but wanted
to do something significant.
And for me, doing
something significant
is serving other
people or a cause
that you can truly
have an impact on.
And when you get into
this space and you
meet so many great people and
you hear so many great stories
about how a dodgy-looking
mustache actually transformed
and changed someone's
life-- beyond the research
we're funding-- and
becomes quite addictive.
And what motivates
me now is we've
done a great job of building
all this financial capital,
and now what's coming
along is this human capital
and the researchers and
connecting them, and just
seeing that interaction and
the progress they're making
is quite amazing.
And there's no other
cancer category
that's able to do this.
If you look at other
cancer categories, at best,
organizations like ours
that are nationally focused,
there's no international
organization like ours
that has that reach and ability
to bring people together.
So for me, it's that impact
and seeing this progress now
on the research side.
That's what gets
me up every day.
As well as this, of course.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I'm actually
in college still.
I'm an intern here.
And I know a lot of college
students take part in Movember,
but a lot of them don't
know what it's about,
and even more don't get
involved in fundraising at all.
So I was wondering if you
have any strategies to sort
of leverage that untapped
potential in terms
of fundraising and just
spreading information
about what it's about?
ADAM GARONE: Yeah.
I mean, we do.
Yeah, there's a lot
of guys that-- I mean,
if you're doing Movember
and you're not registered,
then you're just
a creep, really.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GARONE: So we try
and shame people into it.
But we do.
We have-- and [? JJ's ?] up in
the back of the room there--
a group of people focused
on college engagement.
And it's a market that's turning
over all the time as people
come into and then
leave, and hopefully
type the Movember journey
into their workplace.
So yeah, we've got
active programs
to tap into the college
market through the athletics
apartment, through
the fraternities,
and then champions on campus
to help us spread that message.
Because it is important.
Like the fundraising
part aside, it's
great that people
raise money, but we
don't push that hard on that.
For us, what's really
important is signing up,
because when you
do that, you get
then armed with why it's
important you do it.
And we use growing
mustaches as a Trojan horse
for getting men
involved in this thing.
And that's the most
important thing for us,
that they are
knowledgeable-- or more
knowledgeable than
at start-- and that
will enable them to have that
conversation that matters.
But there's no easy strategy.
It's hard.
But as Movember
becomes more known,
people do realize that
it's important to sign up.
We actually have got a
video-- we'll send it to you--
with Samuel L Jackson
doing the voiceover--
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM GARONE: Yeah.
It's like-- what's the
title of that video?
Do you remember?
It's basically--
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: It's very-- as
you said, it's shaming people.
ADAM GARONE: Yeah,
it's shaming people.
If you don't register,
you're a loser, essentially.
AUDIENCE: Good.
ADAM GARONE: Thanks, mate.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so most of
the marketing and everything
is aimed at men, but more
women-- who may not be able to
also grow a mustache-- how
can they be involved as well?
ADAM GARONE: Yeah, So we've got
a Mo Sista program, and the Mo
Sista program, it's so
critically important for us.
As I mentioned, the Mo Sistas
are often the gatekeeper for us
to participate.
And we encourage that Mo Sistas
sign up as a team captain,
recruit the guys in their
life to be part of their team,
and then encourage them to grow.
A program that I'm
working on, which
we'll look to launch next year,
it's a program called Move.
So the first four letters
of Movember are "move."
And one of the most
important things
you can do for your health
throughout your life
is staying active and moving.
And I don't mean
going to the gym.
I mean just being active.
We've built-- this life.
Because of wonderful
technology, we've
built this sedentary lifestyle.
And there's all this
research coming out now
around the impact of seating
for six to eight hours a day,
and it is as bad if
not worse than smoking.
So if you're sitting for six
to eight hours a day and smoke,
you're in a lot of trouble.
So for us, Move--
next year, you'll
be able to sign up and
make a commitment to move.
And that will enable the
Mo Sistas to do actually
something tangible, make
a tangible commitment
during Movember.
And the way we'll tie
it back to men's health
is if a Mo Sista does
that, they'll then
be encouraged to issue
a challenge to the men
in their life to
match their move.
And it'll be a great
way-- we'll sort of track
that activity then online.
And over time, we'll integrate
the wearable technology
to make sure that
if they're walking
a certain amount
of time per day,
that that's actually happening.
so we're sort of particularly
excited about the Move program,
and as I said, that'll come
to life more next year.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: All right,
so what is your ideal mustache?
ADAM GARONE: Ideal mustache.
This is my go-to stache.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
That's your go-to?
ADAM GARONE: Yeah.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Who has
the most impressive mustache,
of all the guys that you've
met in your journey now?
ADAM GARONE: Oh
I'd have to say--
AUDIENCE: Right here.
ADAM GARONE: That's
a ginger mustache.
That doesn't count.
[LAUGHTER]
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: There is a
very, very powerful ginger Move
team.
I know of this.
ADAM GARONE: Yes.
Who would it be?
Probably Hulk Hogan.
It's impressive.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Yeah.
The Hulkster's been
doing it a long time.
ADAM GARONE: Yeah.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: All right.
Anybody else here?
Any other questions from
the live audience here?
Well, Adam, I want to thank
you so much for being here.
I do want to encourage everyone
that's in this room, everyone
that's watching the
live stream and that's
watching on YouTube to join
on Movember.com sign up.
And Mo Sistas, Mo
Bros, grow a mustache.
ADAM GARONE: Get growing.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Get
the people in your lives.
And at the very least, get
your health check, and--
ADAM GARONE: Create a
conversation that matters.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: That's right.
And let's change the
face of men's health.
Thank you so much
for being here, Adam.
I really appreciate it.
ADAM GARONE: Yeah.
No problem.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]